[Music]  Dancing with the Stars pros Maksim  Chmerkovskiy and Peta Murgatroyd tied  the knot over the weekend he's like  literally the love of my life and that's  it but they weren't the only cute couple  on hand  the groom's younger brother Val and his  girlfriend fellow dancing star Jenna  Johnson were just as adorable Jenna's  stunned in a low-cut black formal gown  her hair and makeup totally glam she  posted this sweet shot with her beau  cuddled up at the venue and also this  silly snap posing in the photo booth  with the bride and groom at the end of  the day we just love each other and  that's that's the bottom line the  festivities continued all weekend long  Val and Jenna attended the post wedding  pool party on Sunday where they were  spotted being affectionate and even  smooched by the pool  [Music]  you